you're ready ready
movies like wrath of man were created
for uh imax theaters and theaters in
general
i am a big sort of fan of seeing
movies on the big screen and always have
been so go
that one extreme further to go into an
imax theater so you get such an
immersive
environment you know the score and the
sound effects
these only come to life when you're in a
in a cinematic
situation so our imax just is like times
10.
larger than life i think experiencing
around the men on the big screen
in as big a screen as possible is is the
way to go about it
because it's one of those films like all
guy ritchie films they're technically
beautifully made this guy richie has a
very interesting visual style
as a filmmaker the action sequences are
tremendous
it's got a tremendous cast of actors so
i think i think people who go and see it
in that format are going to be really
happy
go see it in theaters go see it at imax
getting your ass over to the imax would
be a great idea